hong kong democracy activist joshua wong
has been sentenced to another 10 months
in jail for participating in an
unauthorized protest
wong is one of the most prominent faces
of the pro-democracy movement
he's already serving time in prison for
his role in other protests he was handed
this latest sentence for attending a
vigil commemorating the 1989 tiananmen
square massacre in beijing
three other activists were also
sentenced to between four and six months
behind bars
bring in correspondent phoebe kong who
has the view now from hong kong phoebe
we've just heard this is already the
third time that joshua wong has been
jailed
since 2019 tell us a bit more about this
additional sentence now
last year the annual candlelight vision
in hong kong was
banned by the hong kong police before
the very first time in
decades but joshua and other and other
fellow activists as well as tens of
thousands of people
still turn out to mourn last year on
june 4th
and the judge in a hong kong court today
ruled that
by saying that freedom is not unlimited
that he thought
joshua wong and other defendants
participated in that rally with
political purpose
and which carried potential security
risks and
that's why the court has to send a
deterrent to the society as a whole
by handing down jail sentences
that uh the rally is actually banned by
police citing corona virus restrictions
or rules that uh last year because of
the pandemic
and uh there were actually more than 20
defendants
or prominent thinkers prosecutor for the
participation in that rally
and apart from joshua wong and and
defendants jailed today the rest of them
including jimmy and i will face trial
next month in june
and phoebe this all comes in connection
with a vigil in hong kong last june to
commemorate the tiananmen square
massacre
of course um tell us a little bit more
about you know the the significance of
this as a potential symbol here
yes uh definitely the uh candlelight
vision which is which was held annually
in hong kong
uh has been a tradition like deeply
rooted in hong kong's protest culture
for over 30 years that uh they are to
commemorate
the 1989 uh beijing's crackdown on the
democratic movement in beijing
that um it has been the largest and most
long-standing commemoration around the
world and hong kong used to be the only
place
on chinese soil to do so in the past but
now it seems like
it's becoming a taboo also in hong kong
here
that like through the years until now
the organizers of that
visual they have been calling for an end
to one party rule in china
and that is like a direct challenge to
regime and making is almost
the most sensitive rallies uh like on on
chinese soil
and this is also an indicator of like
how tolerance beijing is towards hong
kong's political descent
so uh since last year the the rallies
was banned for the very first time and
today
this is a favorite sentence against uh
like a peaceful participant
in this candlelight vigil and this is
like uh definitely will be a signal to
the hong kong society as a whole that uh
how likely that people will be able to
carry on their commemoration this year
especially the uh the the june 4
commemoration
next month will be the first one like
under the newly enacted national
security law
and people are really concerned that
whether the organizer will be
like even dissolved by the regime citing
the new security law and
security concerns phoebe kong in hong
kong thank you